Wow wide awake and I'm Greg I am Jenny
Kuwait it's time guys the time is here
Justice League trailer number one we're
both wearing our Batman hats as we
should let's do this
yeah that man myself
we have to be ready you we the others
dissonant actor from far away
not coming it's already here the other
marker curry I'm gana combining
microphonic [ __ ] part you should
probably move
[Music]
whoever you're looking for is not me do
Batman
please NBA justice to never coming
[Music]
whoa
[Music]
what are your superpowers again rich I
was thinking that executive no scream
ever
[Music]
oh it
[Music]
[Music]
shall we Alex gratefully it's good to
see you play well with others again oh
just like a bad idea
[Applause]
ah that was a pretty shitty trailer
that's looking a lot better than I was
expecting I'm not gonna lie yeah it was
really cool actually the tone of the of
the first teaser was also pretty cool
though like this this is building upon
what they showed us before and I think
that they're doing really good this was
the marketing it looks really really
awesome the first part of this trailer
with a Bruce Wayne traveling just kind
of remind me a little bit of Batman
Begins BAM against he's like a wanderer
he has more than all the skills yet but
yeah sly Bremen is that a Batman again
that's that's more simple dinner away
reminded me of I was thinking of Han
Solo in Paris rection
a little bit now cares if we got your
Aquaman talk actually him and yes I like
his voice and he had a funny a spline
too right I don't believe that like yeah
did I dig it right yeah people have been
a little skeptical about cyborg being
all CGI and I was saying that I don't
think like it's that big a deal because
kind of hard to make cyborg not CGI
seeing him and movement and stuff it's
not distracting to me I think like this
visual effects blend well with
cinematography I would disagree for
really yeah I think that that's the one
glaring thing for me like everything
else was on point like level 10 but then
like he shows up and he looks like a CGI
character and I just wish they would go
back to the old days where you to dress
someone up in a cool costume like data
or something like yeah I'm an actual
outfit of some kind overall this is an
awesome package so it's like fine oh
that's cool if you only want to do that
because everything else looks really
good here
my favorite shops of shredders and
they're actually working together
because as much as I love the shots is
like we get Batman here we get off a man
here yes last year and we're like like
like highlight of each other for me is
when Aquaman's riding on top of the
Batmobile right and then he's getting
ready to launch or like and you see that
you see them all standing together and
[ __ ] like that to me looks like really
[ __ ] sweet well what's smart about
this is that it's going into the
relationships that they have with each
other in the dynamics contrast and their
personalities is more with being focused
on here and that's what was lacking in
large part in previous installments in
the series of I will just Batman Menace
feel it's like it was
thing special about the relationships
whereas here there's something fun and
enjoyable about their dynamic yeah it
looks like they're all having a really
good time yeah yeah it looks like you do
regret it looks like this will be a lot
of fun or anything it should be a lot of
fun and the visual effects of course
look great is the [ __ ] DC comic book
movie I think everything was really cool
about it action looks awesome I'm really
excited for the chemistry between Barry
Allen and Bruce Wayne because that looks
like to be one of the funniest parts of
the movie to make I like the the colors
in this better than the Zack Snyder
films it doesn't feel as dark and drab
like Menifee Land and Batman remember
super like almost depressing in terms of
the color tone where this is more light
you know it's more fun yeah this feels
upbeat I feel like the trailers probably
representing the tone of the movie
decently well I don't feel like it's of
an initiative I know B vsi that won
their final trailer was like a really
fun rock and roll trailer and then has
like and it was nothing like the no V
and I feel like here that we starts off
of a white stripes I think the first
long the straighter is a white stripe
song again doing white stretch for
composing the album's word it is movie
it seems like it's representing a town
well it's not a white stretch of queen
those are the two bands and yeah that's
really music these days there's a
certain energy and coolness to that
music that makes the trailer yes really
well I'd like the use have come together
that song that rendition of the film is
really cool and I love that flash apps
Batman you know what's your superpower
again because that's exactly what my
thought was during the Manzo's I'm like
wait but how does that manage it now he
pales in comparison in terms of the
towers but he except the leadership
skills that has an undershoot quality
that's where my thought went next is
like what he's leading the troops like
they need him because he knows how to
pull together and I lost I'm the BBS you
will complain about him using guns and
[ __ ] but it seems like necessary this
time around we were taking on parademons
and stuff I don't have a problem with
him so you take out parademons you know
you shoot them they say all demons you
just shoot I feel like if Devin was a
real person he'd be using guns
I was totally you know what think of it
with the trailers they've been doing is
haven't been showing Superman make a
leading people to believe you might not
even make it appear this ridge enough to
be like Justice Li Part one and Part two
shooting back-to-back - I think that's
still the case Superman supposed to be
in this Justice League movie do you like
if they haven't shown him in the tree
yes because there are people going back
and forth in the comments on the video
the previous video we did for they're
like just show him in the trailer we
know he's in the movie yeah and I mean
they did show in the marketing that he's
in the black Superman suit and stuff so
they did reveal that he is it like
they're behind the scene [ __ ] so they
should just show him but it is doing
something for me where it's getting me
looking forward yeah Superman it's
rebuilding the - cut because I don't
know I feel like the Superman character
has kind of been not taking the best now
I feel like they're kind of going to
reintroduce in just a little bit because
they even they even green with or even
green lighting Man of Steel part 2 right
now that originally was can so I feel
like they're they're going to be
reintroducing him and this is rebuilding
the height and plus it helps keep the
marketing a little more focused yeah I
think when you got like your interviewer
introducing flash Aquaman cyborg and you
got to just keep it all those little
contained so here's my question to you
that's given the nature of this trailer
and the way things are going do you feel
like the studio listen to the people
yeah or this has always been good this
was always going to be like this no they
listen to the people for sure they got
Jeff jobs involved in this and he really
is adding a lot more the humorous touch
in the heart to it but Lois Lane was in
the trailer everyone's favorite
characters in the trailer Lois Lane was
in it and that's semi confirmation that
Superman's definitely going to be in
this one oh but how can we forget where
is he where's the man with the man I'm
most looking forward to seeing over
judge JK Simmons so he's playing
Commissioner Gordon yeah he's
Commissioner Gordon that's really
[ __ ] cool JK Simmons is one of my
favorite actors JK Simmons is the bomb
and he's perfect for a Commissioner
Gordon is especially for the
Commissioner Gordon in this kind of
world JK Simmons looks like he'll fit
the comic book world because this looks
more like a comic book than like The
Dark Knight did write is art nevikov
like the realistic grounded version
Batman right and here this like the
whole all the images look like straight
out of a comic okay I didn't notice it
sometimes but I was looking for Mira
but Billy Crudup I think he's playing
that must be the Flash's dad that's
crazy I didn't really I didn't know
Billy Crudup was Captain Billy Krab is
also met mr. Manhattan and Watchmen Oh a
meme with just knives Oh dr. Manhattan
yeah I call him mr. Manhattan is not a
real doctor to me did catch a brief
moment of Mira played by the woman
Johnny Depp beat up is all remind you of
that really fat one thing I'm a little
concerned about is a little character
overload I mean yeah we've seen Batman
arrays and Wonder Woman's getting her
own movie and Superman but to introduce
like Aquaman cyborg and flash I feel
like is a big thing to do because you
got to give them all the right treatment
sure a lot of people watch the flash
show this is a different flash Aquaman
this is a introduction him no one knows
cyborg really right you know they show
that he does play so he did play
football we need a strong solid
introduction and because you know like
and and just because even with Aquaman
you're knocking off the man you're even
getting is thing off I think Mira's his
wife Aquaman's wife so you're getting
her in there too so you're getting like
a lot of different worlds in there and
then you got a set up with a villains
are and everything run along the movie I
think movies like probably two and a
half hours yeah I mean if it's two and a
half hours that I think you'll have
enough time to do it but if it's only
two hours I think that's that's pregnant
Chloe I think it's a solid 90 minutes I
mean they managed to pull it off with
Avengers I mean albeit all Avengers they
each have their own individual
installments beforehand but I think that
they're really trying to correct what
was done wrong in previous installments
yeah this could be a good one I'm hoping
I'm optimistic about this here I'm
optimistic about it it looks it looks
really cool it seems to deliver all the
Zach's minor visual flares I like the
humorous it was working for me a little
badass I'm really looking forward to
this actually yeah this looks really
cool well thanks to the world for
mentioning this was out and all my
multiple
friends who texted me that it was out
I'm glad I'm awake subscribe to the rail
rejects chebika way is jefita way on the
jab eco a channel and he has his
american video channel Jabby to
youtube.com slash jetty to Jabba cube
give it to it's not a porn site it's not
a porn site that's the most important
piece of information you'll get all day
people I have to go do things now
goodbye